jack ma
comes out and gives a speech on october
24th which i think both
all of us have read or you know you you
read some of the commentary on what he
said
i'll kind of say a couple of the stuff
that he gave the speech on october 24th
he came up he says look i'm a
semi-retired man i'm just jack ma
you know i'm going to give a message to
you today you're either going to think
this is immature
incorrect or laughable but i'm just
going to give this message to you that's
how you kind of set the whole thing up
where he was kind of making him be safe
and then he got up and he started
talking he says look there's three
challenges that we're facing
uh today one is lack of financial system
that china doesn't have a financial
system because we built too fast number
two
innovation must come at a price and
number three
credit management okay and he goes and
talks about
credit management i'm going to read a
couple of these things that he said
which is pretty epic on how we explain
credit management
uh jack ma he goes up and uh in a part
of his speech he says
president xi once said success does not
have to come from me
i understand this phrase to be about a
sense of responsibility about taking
responsibility for the future for
tomorrow for the next generation
many of the world's problems today
including china's can be solved by
innovation
however for real innovation to happen no
one will show you the way and someone
should
show someone must shoulder that
responsibility because innovation is
bound to make mistakes
watch this let me read that one more
time president xi once said success does
not have to come from
me he says in a speech jack ma i
understand this phrase to be about a
sense of responsibility
it takes it's about taking
responsibility for it for the future for
tomorrow for next year many of the
world's promised it including china can
be saw my innovation
however so if you just go president xi
says this i understand he's saying this
however for real innovation to happen no
one will show you the way and someone
must
shoulder the responsibility meaning
president xi
must shoulder the responsibility
because innovation is bound to make
mistakes but the question is not how to
how not to make mistakes but whether we
can perfect
and correct them after making mistakes
and persistently
innovate to make a risk-free innovation
is to stifle innovation
to make risk-free innovation is to start
that's such a
powerful statement to make to make
risk-free innovations to stifle
innovation there is no risk free
innovation in the world there is no such
thing as
as risk-free innovation oftentimes
managing risk down to zero is the
biggest risk
that that phrase is so it's like we just
talked about it right now with bitcoin
oftentimes managing risk down to zero is
the biggest risk
another part of a speech i'll read these
two and i'm gonna turn it over to you
guys
he says today it's really difficult to
regulate ourselves
it's hard to conduct regulation
everywhere around the globe innovation
mainly comes from the marketplace
innovation comes from the grassroots
innovation comes from young people
regulatory challenges are getting bigger
and bigger in fact xeon
which means supervision the first
character in the ward for regulation in
chinese and guan which is the words he
uses
means management the second character in
the word for regulation in chinese
are two different things supervision
means watching you as you develop and
paying attention to your development
management means intervening when there
is a
problem or when there's a foreseeable
problem
we are very good at management but our
supervision ability is
sorely lacking and then the last one is
this the third point
the essence of finance is credit
management we must change the pawnshop
mentality of today's finance and rely on
the development of credit-based
system today's banks continue to have
pawn shop mentality
collaterals and warranties are pawnshops
this was very advanced once upon a time
without innovations like collaterals and
warranties there would be no today
there would be no today's financial
institution and the development of
chinese economy over the past four years
could not have continued he's been the
president and ceo i think of the chinese
entrepreneur club the chairman
and also the president of the xi jiang
general chamber of commerce that same he
said i talked to many entrepreneurs
china's pasha mentality is severe and it
also affects many entrepreneurs
especially entrepreneurs
who have collateralized all their assets
there are also some people who
unscrupulously
take out loans and constantly increase
their leverage taking on more debt
and he explains as i know borrow a
hundred thousand dollars you're afraid
of the bank
if you borrow 10 million dollars both
you and the bank become a pit
bit panic but if you borrow a billion
dollars the bank is afraid of you
there's another habit banks just want to
lend money to the big companies because
they're safe they don't want to lend
money to the small business owners
this is not going to work right anyway
he gives this talk after giving his
21-minute speech
people haven't seen him in public since
and it's now been seven weeks
what do you think is going on over here
wow i'll jump in here this this is a
huge story this
is i think pay very close attention to
this world because this is a microcosm
of what's happening um number one
there's three options for jack ma right
now
he's in custody he's hiding or he's dead
those are
literally i think the three options he's
a very
very smart individual to do what he's
done in a socialist country in a
communist country to be able to build
the epitome of a capitalist company you
know it's unbelievable he's worth 60
billion dollars
we we had this on the docket we were
maybe we were going to talk about jack
ma and the ipo
and in the holding company last week i'm
going why is he throwing
all this out there i thought there was a
shelf life there was a ceiling
for how long he could get away with this
in china
he's just too much like a a world
renowned capitalist for china
so my opinion he's hiding okay
he was planning for this he knew he
knows what the chinese government is
capable of
and he's hiding i don't think you just
go get jack ma
and arrest him like some you know um
like uh
like a reporter whistleblower journalist
in hong kong or something right
okay so i think this is a huge deal i
think he's in hiding
i mean come on he hasn't been seen since
october this is the richest man in china
which is man in china 51 billion yeah
you know what this just opens this
should opens everybody's eyes to what
china is capable of
and and the fact that we aren't taking
them more serious for for
decades china has been a thorn in our
side a menace
now they are like a serious serious
problem that is getting cocky
they can get away with anything and if
their strategy was to eventually control
a political party in this country
control the media i mean they're getting
very very close to checking off a couple
boxes
they they're strategic they are marching
towards an end game that only they know
and this is scary the fact that jack ma
can just disappear
my opinion is he's hiding he's got the
resources to do it he's planned for it
for years and he's somewhere on some
island
that's what i think yeah you brought up
a couple key words uh
number one being control so let's just
paint a picture of
who this would be in the united if
you're not familiar with jack ma this is
the equivalent of
jeff bezos saying some bad things about
the us government about trump
very normal in america and it happens
every single day every day
if um tim cook said something about
uh trump it'd be like on the today's
news and gone the next day right
the rock says something about trump all
right we'd laugh and joke about it it's
gone
jack ma says a couple things about uh
the ccp and
and president xi is missing for almost
two months
this is what's this is life in china and
i actually want to want to throw it to
you
to to get your opinion on the it's like
uh it's socialism at the at the
government side but capitalism and the
working thing
but the thing that that tom brought up
and i kind of had some notes on is
this is about control with alibaba
and ant group and everything that he's
doing he has access to
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
people ultimately
more than a billion people potentially
who can go directly to his business that
he
ccp has no control over what he's able
to do
and i think what do you mean meaning he
clearly they do not like what he has to
say wait so ccp has no control over what
they can do
to him no no no no they don't like that
he has access to all these people his
company has access to all these people
yeah with and and can can what
that's my question is like what is the
control that the communism
how it works tell me how it works
everything is if you bow down to the
regime
yes then you get what you get okay which
he has done clearly
for years one thing you do not do in
china is
calling out president xi right
you do not do that buddy and he crossed
the line okay
so so imagine so so go to the setting go
to the setting
so it's october 24th he's giving a
speech speech ends
he walks off he gets text messages his
attorney calls him his peers call him
his attorney probably told him don't
give the speech did he contact his
attorney say read the speech this is
what i want to read an attorney said
don't do it you think you talk to his
attorney maybe he didn't talk to his
attorney did he pull off a jerry maguire
i'm just going to go and give this
speech
i don't know did he take anyone's advice
maybe he didn't take anyone's advice
if he did take someone's advice what
happened there say he didn't take
someone's advice he gives a speech
right afterwards what are people texting
him
what was that all about bro what were
you talking about then what else was he
happening maybe the talking was he
arrested right on the spot yeah
maybe maybe there were people there
saying here follow us somebody wants to
talk to you and
go there he's disappearing right maybe
right after he's like dude i gotta give
so his friend says you need to leave
asap get
on a private jet on leaves and go
somewhere else no one knows no one knows
what happened right now with a guy like
this by the way it's been nine weeks i
said seven weeks
it's been nine weeks it's been two
months yeah it's been two months over
two months since this happened
no one knows but here's a rule of thumb
you know the whole thing started with
these guys wanting to break apart the
ant group right you know this
it's too big you guys are too big we got
to find a way to
you know break this thing apart and et
cetera center this guy's a rich guy
billionaire all this other stuff the ipo
all this mess that was being talked
about right here's how the chinese
regulators slam the brakes on the firms
would be record-breaking 37 billion ipo
wait we're not doing this right that's
that's kind of how this whole thing came
about
the calls he got right afterwards
dude if they come and get this guy and
they're sitting with them
here's what china is now dealing with if
he disappears
and they kill him what happens to china
go through all the situations
that's a that's a pr nightmare to for
china
are you kidding me that richest man in
china ends up being dead after he so
talks trash pr nightmare yes
so uh the ant group uh ipo is halted
after the speech right yeah that makes
sense of course yeah so
so so they kill them so nightmare what's
the possibility of being killed by the
way
hi that he that that it happened yeah
oh so you think it's possible that he
got killed i i'm thinking it is possible
okay it's possible okay yeah all right
i think he's go go let me go
okay so but china has to process if they
do anything to this guy hey
how dare you talk about us this way this
is
what i think would happen they bring
them in
they say hey we've known for the last 20
years that you're going to have a lot of
influence in the country
so we've had 300 of your employees that
have been insiders reporting to ccp
and we have recordings of you of 7 000
hours and these are some of the things
that you've said
and they're going to play it for them
and then we know some of your habits and
what kind of girls you like and what
kind of this you like and what kind of
that you like and what kind of dish you
like
we want you to look at this packet okay
we
are going to train you to come out and
you are going to say
great things about china like you've
never said before for the rest of your
life because if you don't
you're going to lose this this this this
this this this that
do you commit to that of what do you
think is going to say
yes if jack comes out
and in the next six months 12 months you
see him speaking very
very highly about china that's what took
place
okay right they got something on them by
the way it's not a china thing that's
everything every country same thing
what's happening in russia america
that's everywhere that's not about you
know
that that's nothing new so i'm not
putting that on china that's a tactic
that being used
for a very very long time when it comes
down to things like saying if you have
dirt on somebody you call them into a
room and yeah
this is a different kind of dirt this is
an internal manipulation you know trying
to go on the inside getting you
all this other stuff you think china
doesn't know that jack was a threat to
them because jack was pretty opinionated
and he's connected with america and he's
admired and loved and enamored and all
this others of course
they know that so i think china is smart
enough to not go there but at the same
time
do you think china gives a [ __ ] what the
rest of the world thinks
no do you think they really do i don't
think china does
and if you like that
what do you think china cares more about
do you think china cares more about
their system their values their
principles what they do than what do you
think about
how they handle someone yeah yes but if
you start questioning their system
that's when i think they get a little
holder like the everything that happened
with dara mori in the nba are you
thinking the hong kong protest do you
think
china is the kind of player where this
is what happens let me give you a
scenario you know how a player screws up
and they come out and next thing they
say what
i just want to say on behalf of my
family i'm very disappointed in my
behavior this is not
uh something that i do i let down
they're not going to apologize
do you think that's china no no no china
is not going to china's going to say no
that's who we are
this is our system period we don't
apologize for that and they don't want
you they don't want people
questioning it you do not do that
to china yeah yeah especially when
you're the richest man in china
and china's getting to the point too
like what other country can say anything
negative about them
what an african country a european
country they have influence everywhere
you think joe biden's going to like call
them out on whatever has happened to
jack ma
two things do you think the chinese
government takes over his company number
one do they think
do you think they allow him to continue
to run it like he has been and number
two
do you think he's gotten too comfortable
i do i think when you
when you have a worldwide business like
that and you travel to the united states
you see how this is
i think he got a little comfortable i
think he lost grasp of just
what they can do to him in his home
country is it comfortable or cocky it's
a big difference
is is it comfortable or cocky i'm gonna
say comfortable okay because i think
he's got enough of an edge where he
wouldn't allow himself to get cocky to
be able to build that business out of a
one-bedroom apartment like he did so i
think it's comfort as opposed to cocky
because i don't think you can get that
cocky in china because there's constant
reminders that we will squash you
so i think it's just a level of comfort
private jet g5 to the us
you know to monaco to the south of
france wherever you want to go
and you forget this is where i'm from
these guys really do have their thumb on
me and they can press me down at any
time
pat you know what i think would be uh
helpful
for i mean i i'd like to know and maybe
our viewers would like to know
because i know you've done a lot of
interviews regarding china
obviously um general spalding and
everything with that
how does the system actually work with
the communist ccp
you know socialist agenda like don't
question it versus
yeah we allow capitalism to happen on
the uh on the ground
so to speak how do they have that
balance how does that work it's
capitalism
with respecting the top okay you cannot
question the top
you cannot say hey you're not doing this
right you're not doing that right
there is none of that going on you're
not going to see a china media calling
out what president xi is doing you're
not going to wake up in the morning
again see a cnn or a fox type of a
situation it's not going to happen there
it's not a kind of a situation where
they're bashing each other you cannot do
that
like a cnn of the world calling out
trump or a fox of the world calling out
obama that's not going to happen in
china
on the media side but that's everything
that's everything so they say listen
you want to do business go ahead do
business that's longest as long as you
don't disrespect and you
do what we do to do okay the culture
so how does the cap yeah
it's like the mob but so but how does
that hinder
you know entrepreneurship capitalism you
know free spirit
well what what hinders what happens
there okay so give me the dna of an
entrepreneur
i mean everything we talk about every
single day toughness grit sticking it
out work ethic
principles of an entrepreneur is what i
think
i can do it better than the government
so president
so so jack gives a speech about how he
thinks he can do it better and he talks
about lack of financial system
innovation must
come at a price and credit management he
thinks he can do it better
is he inspired for him to be a president
is he inspired politically for himself
does he want to kind of take the next
step is he kind of want to be the trump
or he wants to go out there and say
i want to go is he a threat to president
president xi because he's speaking at a
time where he can be a more
world leader type of person where he has
connection with china but he can also
speak english he's very eloquent where
he can be more a
global type of a power is he trying to
play a power play to take the next
position of life for himself
does he want that i don't know i do know
the way he started it he says
my message is either immature incorrect
laughable and i'm semi-retired
a person who wants to be a president
probably wouldn't start a speech like
that yeah
immature incorrect laughable and i'm
semi retired why would you not say
that he's got like those words is that
no to say if you think i'm immature for
saying this
i i said i it may be immature so i'm
agreeing with you immature i may be
incorrect you're right i am incorrect
it may be laughable you're right i do
agree with you that i may be laughable
so
if you disagree please know that i'm
also in agreement with you
so to to button this up because i know
we need to probably move
tom laid out three very viable scenarios
right he's either dead
he's in uh hiding or he's in custody
what's your vote
i don't i don't know i honestly i i
could nobody knows yeah
i i don't think he's dead that's number
one so i take the debt out i don't think
he's dead
um i don't think even with all the
private airports and how to leave the
country
fast without somebody saying he's
leaving
if he left early before somebody coming
after him
because i don't know the speed of how
quickly this was related to the power
people if he's given a speech
somebody in there is sitting there
texting the right people that are
working directly with g to say here's
what we just said
and here's a recording somebody so 21
minutes i listen to them boom call them
i think if they wanted them they'd be
there so i i couldn't tell you i'd love
to hear what the audience thinks
yeah jonathan lee reynoldso says if i
give ten bucks if china really killed ma
what will that do to the future of
unicorns other countries need to market
china entrepreneurs
and offer them a safe haven you know i i
i don't disagree so i'm saying i don't
think that's the case
he may be in custody he may be hiding
probably more
probably more custody than hiding i
think it's more custody and revealing
the stuff that they have on him to bring
him back and train him for a few months
of how to sound and look like when he
gets on camera
maybe i think it's more training right
re-education that's educational like
they have like the uyghur
it's like when the mob went through this
week i interviewed a guy named um
jack falcone now jack falcon which was
fascinating he talked stories about greg
de palma
the mob uh era he was an fbi agent
undercover 24 out of 26 years
where he was undercover no but i talked
to dr cyril wecht i don't know if you
know who dr cyril wecht is he's the
number one pathologist
award-winning pathologist for the last
six years he's done 21 000 autopsies
okay 21 000 and 41 000 he's monitored
and supervised 41 000 that he signed off
on
he held the elvis brain etcetera there's
a lot of dead bodies yeah that's a lot
of dead
got some very very good stories that
we're talking about
uh you know i i i don't i don't know
i don't know i don't know i don't i
almost don't want to say what i want to
say here with this but
what do you mean no no no no no
yeah i don't i don't know uh oh you know
he has to surface at some point
and then the question is will he talk
will he give the back it doesn't have to
surface because
the guys the mob went to j edgar hoover
and said hey here's pictures of you we
know you're a cross stretcher
you're gay hey shut up leave us alone
don't say anything anymore
j groover went to kennedy and said hey
here's the pictures i got about marilyn
monroe okay so you got to stay quiet
or else okay so that's like a regular
thing so
hey chinese ccp hey jackman this is what
we got on you moving forward
here's your script here's this we need
you to sign this up if you don't we're
going to ruin your life what do you want
to do
and we're going to train you for the
next couple months until you agree to
this i think that's what's going on he
could be a big piece of propaganda for
them right a big selling point i think
so
i think so tom hear the pictures i have
of you lauren sanchez
uh had your 30th birthday wrong i was an
observer that's it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
you